il avait promis hier de venger la mort
de 24 civiles russes tués à Belgorod
Vladimir Poutine n'a pas tardé à
concrétiser sa menace la Russie a
effectivement lancé ce matin une pluie
de missile sur le territoire ukrainien
selon l'armée ukrainienne 99 missiles
ont été tirés 72 ont été interceptés les
villes de carkiv et Kiev notamment ont
été massivement bombardé vous le voyez
et ce bilan qui nous est communiqué
bilan provisoire au moins quatre morts
dont une victime dans la la capitale
ukrainienne au moins 10 puissantes
explosions ont été entendues ce matin
vous vous trouvez à Kiev Michel Benamou
bonjour vous êtes directeur de
l'Institut opoui vous êtes par ailleurs
ancien conseiller politique de l'armée
française je crois que tout est allé
assez vite ce matin des alertes ont été
lancées un peu partout dans le pays des
alertes appelant la population à à se
mettre à l'abé
oui on est souvent revé par des alertes
ici mais là on a été réveillé par des
par des détonations par des bombes en
fait et c'est moi ça qui m'a réveillé
très très franchement vers 7h 20 une
succession d'explosion 34 et puis ça
s'est enchaîné ensuite jusqu'à 8h30 9h
ça s'est arrêté vers vers 9h après le
discours de Vladimir Poutine hier et ses
menaces proféré le président russe
parlait de vouloir venger les victimes
civiles russes vous vous attendiez à une
telle réponse oui la population s'y
attendait on avait des rumeurs et donc
beaucoup de gens se sont cachés dans le
métro tôt ce matin et oui et puis il y a
eu aussi le choc du 29 décembre et ce
qui s'est passé ce matin se rajoute à ce
choc du du 29 en proportion on est à peu
près avec le même nombre de frappes même
diversité aussi de de frappe et donc
voilà une semaine un peu compliquée ici
quand même h un début d'année difficile
99 missiles lancés sur le pays indique
l'armée ukrainienne ça s'est déjà vu par
le le passé on on commémorera bientôt
les les 2 ans du début de cette cette
guerre comment est-ce que vous vous vous
l'interprétez qu'est-ce que vous voyez
dans cette dans cette réponse russe
aujourd'hui bah une fatigue en tout cas
ici à Kief on n' pas fêté le nouvel an
comme on l'avait fêté l'an dernier où il
y avait beaucoup plus d'enthousiasme en
fait hein après 2 ans de guerre les
Ukrainiens sont sont fatigués toujours
résilients hein ils ont je pense dans
l'ensemble toujours envie de se battre
hein parce qu'en fait ils ont pas le
choix très franchement mais euh mais de
la de la fatigue et très peu de fêtes
très peu de célébrations le 31 décembre
par exemple HM très peu de célébration
le cœur pas vraiment à la fête et on
peut le le comprendre
bientôt ces 2 ans qui seront marqués de
quelle manière d'ailleurs à Kiev la
capitale comment est-ce qu'elle
appréhende cet anniversaire cette date
anniversaire au vu de ce qui se passe
sur le
terrain je sais pas s'il y a des
événements prévus pour ça je pense que
les ucrainiens sont surtout constate que
la contreoffensive n'a pas fonctionné
l'an dernier il constate aussi que les
Américains sont sont en train de revoir
leur engagement ils s'inquiètent d'une
élection de de Trump en novembre
prochain
euh et voilà tout le monde se demande si
le front pourra pourra tenir pour
l'instant il tient euh mais sans
armement sans équipement la situation
sera difficile sur le plan tactique
justement mais je pense pas qu'il n'y
aura de célébration particulière en tout
cas dans d'ici quelques semaines le chef
de la diplomatie
ukrainienne vient de vient de s'adresser
au aux alliés de l'Ouest ce matin
appelle à à faire davantage beaucoup
plus vite pour la livraison d'armes pour
pour pour le combat pour avancer sur le
terrain volodimir Zelenski dénonce lui
une campagne de de terreur russe
aujourd'hui quels sont les les moyens
aujourd'hui de de l'Ukraine pour
poursuivre cette
guerre l'Ukraine a toujours des
équipements conséquent il faut le
rappeler même si les Américains sont en
train deevoir leur engagement les armes
continuent à à venir que ce soit petit
calibre artillerie défense aérienne on a
eu aussi un communiqué intéressant des
Anglais is ce matin disant que
l'Angleterre avec d'autres alliés
prévoyait un soutien européen en cas de
retrait total américain donc ça ça
relevé le moral des troupes un peu ici
quand même euh mais oui il est probable
que en 2024 il y ait une asymétrie en
faveur des Russes cette fois-ci h vous
sentez que la Russie peu à peu prend
prend l'avantage c'est ça que vous êtes
en train de dire
aujourd'hui on l'avait prévu hein je
pense pas mal d'analystes militaires
l'avaent prévu dès 2023 on savait hein
que les occidentaux n'avait pas euh les
équipements les ressources des capacités
de production suffisantes en 2024 et que
les Russes avec l'appui de leurs alliés
euh serait serait plus fort que nous
dans ce domaineel en 2024 et
effectivement cette tendance se se
confirme merci beaucoup Michel Benamou
en direct de Kiev pour votre témoignage